nach insgesamt 15 Stunden Flugzeit bin
ich endlich in Tokyo angekommen und ich
war noch nie in meinem Leben so lost
aber mal von Anfang an im Flugzeug gab
es einen süßen puddingauflauf und
Joghurt mit Obst angekommen in Tokyo ist
mir als erstes aufgefallen dass die
Toiletten total Hightech sind hier
gibt's einfach einen Knopf für Musik da
wir alles sehr spontan gebucht haben
mussten wir den Japan Rail Pass also das
Zugticket vor Ort besorgen das hat uns
zwei Stunden gekostet und mit 350 € pro
Person für eine Woche auch noch eine
halbe nier unsere Unterkunft ist direkt
neben dem Shibuya crossing die wohl
beliebteste Kreuzung der Welt wenn die
Ampeln grün leuchten überqueren zwei
2500 Menschen auf einmal die Straße auf
der Suche nach Abendessen wurde mir erst
klar wie Lost wir eigentlich sind wir
können kein Japanisch und die Japaner
können kein Englisch viele Gerichte
werden hier mit schweinebrühe gekocht
aber ich habe da noch was gefunden wo
wir vegetarische Rahmen bekommen haben
danach haben wir ein japanischen
Supermarkt besucht wo es Mochi Donuts
gedämpften Cheesecake und Baumkuchen gab
soll ich den kaufen und probieren
schreibt mir gerne mal re